no way they did it to us again Jutsu
kaisit is absolutely insane right now
with Yuji mastering reverse curse
technique Against full power sukuna
clues that characters who we think are
dead might not really be dead and that
twist at the very end was incredible and
jaw-dropping so let's get into it in the
previous chapter we saw just how
impressed sukuna was with higuma
abilities and sukuna even said that
higuma could use his curse technique
almost as effectively as he himself
suguna then acknowledged uruma as a the
opponent so knowing G this was a sure
sign that Pur higuma was about to die
now Yuji was also there during the
sukuna fight with higuma and sukuna had
only the opposite to say about Yuji far
from acknowledging him sukuna mocked
Yuji and called him boring then he
delivered a serious injury to yuji's
abdomen which took Yuji out of the fight
for the time being poor higuma even
learned to use reverse curse technique
on the spot and he managed to stab
sukuna through the hand with the
Executioner sword but sukuna just cut
off his hand and then kept going higuma
then seemingly decided to sacrifice his
own life in order to bestow the power of
wielding the Executioner sword onto Yuji
and Yuji by the way had somehow managed
to recover from his injury and get back
into the fight we weren't sure how
exactly higuma was planning to make the
transfer to Yuji but it seemed like he
might have made some sort of binding Vow
where he gives up his own life in
exchange for Yuji keeping the
Executioner sword after his death the
chapter ended with Yuji seemingly using
the Executioner sword to stab sukunai in
the back but in my review I warned you
guys not to fall for it there is no way
that g was going to make it so easy the
latest chapter confirms my words
immediately as yuji's attack has no
effect on sukuna and then the sword just
kind of like shrinks and disappears from
yuji's hand Yuji isn't sure what's
happening and he calls out hig's name
but he doesn't have much time to analyze
the situation because sukuna immediately
attacks him with a barrage of punches
sukuna punches Yuji slashes him and Yuji
is thrown backwards nevertheless sukuna
is impressed by the fact that Yuji is
still alive the fact that the injury he
suffered at the hands of sukunai in the
last chapter didn't kill him means that
Yuji almost certainly managed to master
reverse curse technique sometime in the
past month sukuna then sees we we or PE
or whatever his name is preparing to use
his teleportation technique as Kirara
holds up hig's body right next to UI
sukuna then concludes that the sorcerers
have been using teleportation to take
the injured off the battlefield and
bring them to shoko because shoko is
able to use reverse curse technique to
heal not only herself but also others
and this confirms that yeah pp's curse
technique is indeed teleportation now
the fact that the sorcerers are taking
the time and the risk to teleport higuma
shoko tells me that he might still be
alive otherwise what would be the point
of risking your own life to teleport a
dead body this might also explain why
yuji's attack against sukuna was
ineffective if higuma was prepared to
sacrifice his life to allow Yuji to
wield the Executioner sword possibly
through some sort of binding vow then if
higuma didn't actually die the power to
wield the sword would not be
successfully transferred to Yuji and I
mean if this is what's happening all of
it makes sense strategically the
sorcerers are using teleportation to
take the injured off the battlefield and
heal them so that they can live to fight
another day that makes a lot of sense
but taking dead bodies and trying to
teleport them when you could be struck
down by sukuna at any moment doesn't
make nearly as much sense sukuna then
says something extremely interesting he
tells us that Gojo's corpse vanished
after sukuna apparently killed him and
it must have disappeared because of
these people they must have also
transferred Gojo to shoko I will come
back to this crazy Gojo thing in a
little bit because it could be huge but
sukuna then moves on from this topic
because he concludes that Yuji wasn't
healed by shoko which means that in just
a month Yugi must have learned to use
reverse curse technique himself and so
he was the one who healed himself after
that massive injury injy upon learning
this sukuna surprises even himself by
the fact that he seems to be upset at
yuji's success even Yuji is caught off
guard by Suk kuna's uncharacteristic
Behavior because sukuna appears like he
is deep in thought and spacing out
instead of giving all of his Focus to
the fight sukuna himself isn't even sure
what is bothering him so much it
shouldn't be the death of Kaku or
anything along those lines since he
doesn't let his mood depend on other
people for sukuna other people are just
some amusement to fill up his time while
he's in this world so why should he care
about what happens to any of them the
key factor here appears to be Yuji Yuji
bothers sukuna so much because sukuna
spent time coexisting with Yuji inside
the same body so sukuna feels like he
knows Yuji better than he knows other
people and the one thing that sukuna
keeps coming back to with Yuji is his
Fierce determination to never give up no
matter how many times Yuji experiences
defeat and tragedy and heartbreak he
just keeps coming back and giving it all
all he's got despite being a massive
Underdog Yuji keeps tirelessly fighting
on Against All Odds this is yuji's ideal
his purpose his reason for being and as
someone who can never be an underdog
because he is literally the strongest
sorcerer in history sukuna can never
experience the courage determination and
purpose of someone like Yuji because he
spent time inside yuji's body sukuna
knows that yuji's ideals and
determination are genuine he knows that
Yuji is not protect ending and so sukuna
knows that Yuji is the real deal he is
the underdog Warrior striving with all
of his being and risking everything to
defeat a villain much stronger than he
is and this is the kind of thrill that
sukuna himself can never experience I
think this is why Yuji bugs sukuna so
much I think sukuna is a little bit
jealous of Yuji and so the villain is
determined to destroy Yuji both mentally
and physically he wants to not only
defeat Yuji he wants to also crush his
hope and his ideals then suddenly a new
rule is added to the culling game rule
15 states that megumi fushiguro will be
the one with the authority to activate
the merger between Master Tangen and the
rest of humanity this seems to have been
kaku's final act his insurance policy in
case he died before his dream of human
evolution could be realized now of
course sukuna is currently inside
megumi's body so he has the authority to
initiate the merger but the sorcerer
didn't initially believe that sukuna
would ever want to pursue kaku's goals
sukuna is not a mad scientist who wants
to experiment on Humanity out of
curiosity so hopefully sukuna will have
no interest in finishing what Kaku
started unfortunately it seems that
sukuna might have been the successor of
kaku's will after all sukuna says to
Yuji that first he is going to kill him
after that he's going to kill all the
players in the culling game and then he
will in fact allow Tangen to merge with
Humanity depending on what what kind of
entity will emerge from this merger
sukuna wants to play with this new
entity in other words sukuna is not
interested in human evolution per se
like kenju was but he is interested in
fighting the ultimate opponent and this
entity that will emerge from the merger
of tenen with the rest of humanity could
be the ultimate opponent that sukuna has
been looking for but before sukuna can
put a stop to yuji's determination once
and for all the one and only Utah kotu
shows up out of nowhere and attacks
sukuna as he destroys like half a city
block with his sword Utah apologizes for
being late and then he engages sukuna in
a brutal battle sukuna makes it clear to
Utah that he better do his best because
if he doesn't kill sukuna now sukuna
will kill all his friends and classmates
and just as the king of curses is
getting cocky and threatening Utah ra
emerges and violently attacks sukuna as
the narrator declares that the king of
curses and the queen of curses are
finally going to battle it out to to see
who will sit on the throne in the end
now of course we all knew that after
Gojo's apparent death UT and Rica would
have to join the battle against sukuna
if they want the sorcerers to have even
a small chance of actually winning
against the king of curses personally I
thought that UTA would join even earlier
but he surprised me by first suddenly
killing kenju and then rushing back to
the sight of the battle with suguna
huruma seems like he might still be
alive but he's effectively out of the
picture for now so it's all about Utah
and Yuji versus sukuna although we might
get some possible assistance from Side
characters like kusaka and Eno
personally I would still love to see
Utah the expert swordsman wielding the
Executioner sword against sukuna if that
is even possible at this point but we'll
have to wait and see how the battle is
going to go down I am super excited to
see what Raa UTA and Yuji together can
do against sukuna and if you're excited
as well drop a like and comment right
now to let me know I can't wait to see
what happens next okay now back to the
part about Gojo's body disappearing from
the battlefield and sukuna assuming that
it was taken by shoko as a professional
Gojo coper this was extremely
interesting to me because as we know
Gojo's head was not damaged when he was
quote unquote killed by sukuna so there
could still be some chance however small
that Gojo with shoko's help could find a
way to use reverse curse technique to
somehow heal himself maybe shoko can do
just enough to get it started and then
Gojo can do the rest or something along
those lines
I mean we know that Yuji was literally
dead for like days and then came back to
life so this kind of thing is possible
in jjk Yuji was able to do this because
he made a deal with sukuna but Gojo's
power is comparable to sukuna so maybe
he too can find some way to return
especially with shoko helping him I know
I know I'm coping feel free to ignore my
ramblings but if you want to continue
coping with me check out this video
where I talk about how Gojo could return
from the dead as a vengeful spirit and
surpass Humanity just like Master Tangen
link on screen and in the description